hallo leute hier ist wieder eure mal ban
ich weiß ihr braucht ist mein moment um
diese großartige weihnachtliche deko zu
bestaunen weihnachtlich ihr habt das
video aus zwei möglichen gründen
angeklickt entweder ihr seid so wie ich
und schaut einfach jedes video ihrer
lieblings youtube oder habt ihr ganzes
geld für starbucks café unter dem motto
ausgegeben aber möchte trotzdem jemanden
gerne ein adventskalender schenken was
by the way jetzt auch wirklich last
minute ist doch keine sorge genau das
ist meine spezialität
so habe ich es nämlich auch durch die
schule geschafft wenn mein gehirn
funktioniert bei druck einfach am besten
was nicht gerade praktisch ist mein
youtuber sein will hier macht ihn
nämlich absolut kein druck außer die
community vielleicht aber egal ich hoffe
dass ich mit meinen ideen weiterhelfen
kann und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
was nicht explodiert hier maßnahme aus
jetzt habe ich ein bisschen angst
bekommen und ich entschuldige mich für
den lichtwechsel aber an poltergeister
tlm eine glühbirne irgendwie eingenommen
ist gehört meine glühbirne dem satan
machen wir weiter erste adventskalender
ist für menschen gemacht die mit euch in
derselben wohnung dafür braucht ihr nur
postels kreide maler fotos papiere
stifter eine schere also alles was sie
schon zu hause hatten ist auch nichts
dafür einkaufen wenn ihr das nicht wollt
und dann geht es auch schon los und da
ist eure kreativität auch ein bisschen
wichtig sucht euch einen schönen spruch
raus und martin mit dem kreide maler an
spiegel oder fenster in der wohnung am
besten so eine schöne art facebook spur
ganz wichtig nimmt keinen stück den mann
nicht wieder abbekommen denn sonst ist
die überraschung überhaupt nicht schön
und jetzt macht ihr noch ein türchen
drum herum gestaltet ist ein bisschen
fertig wer aber keine kreide maler hat
kann zum beispiel auch ein foto und ein
post-it nehmen und die süße überraschung
am morgen ist gesichert und wenn man
ganz kreativ unterwegs ist dann man sich
einfach ein blatt papier und gestaltet
es kann aber auch jeden tag eine
einfache technik und am besten ist wenn
ihr euch für jeden tag etwas anderes
ausdenken könnte es immer an die gleiche
stelle packen oder sogar eine kleine
spitze jagt raus macht nutzt einfach
eure
kasey adventskalender nummer zwei ist
noch einfacher und für menschen gedacht
die nicht mit euch unter einem dach
leben ich nenne ihnen liebevoll den
whatsapp adventskalender für den müsse
zwar auch kreativ sein aber der aufwand
ist quasi gleich 0 schickte ausgewählten
personen jeden tag eine botschaft es
kann zum beispiel ein text sein renz
hell wie ein link zu einem song durch
verbindet oder last christmas falls sie
diese person nerven wollt auch da habt
ihr wieder komplett freie auswahl das
wichtigste hier ist nur dass ihr jedes
mal dazu schreibt und welches türchen es
sich handeln ohne flachs jetzt ja ich
glaube dass der kalender richtig gut
ankommen ihr steckt das war überhaupt
kein cent rein aber so viel mühe und
liebe
dass er am ende noch 1000 millionen mal
mehr wert ist und das waren auch schon
meine ideen keine ahnung warum ich das
gerade getan habe und noch ein kleiner
tipp für die leute die keinen
adventskalender haben aber gerne einen
hätten man kann online ganz viele finden
bei denen man preise gewinnen kann und
so und das ist doch auch ein kleiner
trost alexy wächst zum beispiel der
macht jedes jahr ein und wenn man bei
google eingibt dann findet man sofort
ein wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
video peace out eine info noch für euch
im dezember geht ja wieder blog miss los
und das heißt ich werde wieder liebes
tagebuch hochladen
ich hoffe euch gefällt das wenn ja dann
schreibt mir doch in die kommentare was
ihr denn gerne sehen wollt mehr von
meinem privaten leben
bis dann tschüss